next to me it's pretty dark and
everything
and
i felt an arm around me and so i got up
in shock and i'm like what the hell are
you doing and he was like well i thought
you was my girl and i'm like no
uh
what are you doing in here um and he's
like well you know um i'm sorry i didn't
know it was you you know miss sharon you
know i've been meaning to talk to you
and i'm like well um can it wait like um
is it really that
so i'm like fine if you really need to
talk i need you to
get up and put on some clothes
and then we can talk about it i can't
stand those nails as i was all right now
we're back in the process of telling him
this
that's when my daughter came in the room
um i'm assuming she must have heard us
talking or whatever she walks in she
sees or she heard him busting those
cheeks fast not slow
like i like my women in the bed
of course she's thinking the words like
you guys are sleeping together like mom
how dare you do me like this how could
you you know um
and
of course she's in a fit of rage i mean
she had every right uh were we wrong for
being in the bed together yes okay sorry
i'll keep going yes but you guys need to
understand that i let him know that he
needed to get up and he needed to put on
some clothes if he wanted to talk to me
because i felt it was inappropriate so
timing is everything and unfortunately
my daughter walked in on on us and
spazzed the [ __ ] out which she had every
right to so um me and my daughter are
not talking
we haven't talked since this whole
incident um
i haven't been there
i just want to be able to
like i said um you know have my daughter
understand what really happened she
hasn't even given me a chance to even
explain anything good she just shut down
and she wants nothing to do with me or
him so
um i don't know what else to do guys um
maybe you know if someone's listening
contact maury jerry springer or somebody
because
i would really love to you know for my
daughter to understand what really
happened and to know that she said what
her mom would never do anything what up
guys
right flynn
she double down the audacity
yo she said call jerry call maury
like
what in the actual world
you don't want to talk to your daughter
you want fame girlfriend that's what she
wants she wants to double down in her
fame and that getting the numbers up
what what is wrong with you
go to your daughter's house and have a
conversation with her like you don't
need freaking jerry springer
okay
this is this is why this is why this is
so stupid like you think you need to go
on these like judge judy like jerry
springer shows you're gonna get more
attention and that's all you want you
want all this clout so that you can like
make some money off of it
well didn't you guys always think that
the people that went on jerry springer
and maury were a little bit off like
especially the women that were like
running and screaming like you are not
the father like
that was the real audacity of the 90s
that you would go on a show and you're
like well i mean it's 50 50 shots it's
like him or this other dude but you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna try it i'm
gonna come out on top and the women
and the women that would come back five
times you just be like
come on
like i don't care how much how much you
get paid you can't get paid that much
just like and your reputation is ruined
forever
i had a family member go on a reality
show once it was not
what it what happened
well so he was a
he was an actor and he pretended to be
gay and we were all like bruh like what
like
but at least you find out that it's
scripted you know what i mean
i just can't believe this woman she's
gaslighting the internet the whole
internet not only did you gaslight your
daughter you guess what me the audacity
i just i just can't get with the nails
and the the smudged eyeliner like you
want us to feel bad for you
you're you mean to tell me
that you got in the bed
and he like slipped in the bed and you
didn't see each other you didn't know
that your fellas
yeah like he
what is wrong with you you obviously
knew he busted the cheeks for sure or at
least tried i don't know but
oh my gosh like to think that to think
that like if my mom ever did that oh my
gosh that was that's disgusting like
literally this girl should never speak
to both of these people like
cut them off for good it's just insane
that we're that we live in this world
you know i know the manosphere that says
cheating is different for men and for
women and you know
i i agree to some level
but then they're screwing your girl's
mom
i don't know what i don't know what the
line is
but i think he crossed it
anybody in the chat you ever hooked up
with a girl's family member like her mom
her auntie her grandma be honest be
honest don't lie
any dude did that he'd be literally dead
to me oh my god if i even heard that he
like
attempted with any of my relatives dead
dead to me
there was this one woman um she i think
she posted a tick tock about it she was
in her like mansion in the kitchen and
she was like oh um
i ins i dumped my boyfriend and got with
his dad and now i have an awesome
stepson oh yeah that's a whole tick tock
premise she's like this this young um
like like african dark woman like
gorgeous and
then she's like married to this old
white guy and she's just like her whole
tick tock page is just crapping on her
stepson
[Music]
and i i want i want to know if it's real
like the husband's real like i've seen
him but i haven't seen like the stepson
but i also think that there's women out
there that have done it like oh 100
100
that is a real thing
that is definitely a real thing
do you know what
someone put but
but she told her daughter that she
wasn't treating the baby daddy right in
the original video hmm
look at i don't know what the line is
but you could tell your daughter you're
not treating your boyfriend right and
not screw him
yeah and if you weren't actually
screwing him you wouldn't say things
like that in the middle of like the
argument you would have just been like
oh like he got in the bed that's so
weird yadda yadda right you wouldn't
like overreact
if it was just oh he just was in the bed
like i didn't know he was here i was
sleeping whatever
but no obviously she was caught
in a lie so she doubled down and was
like now i gotta give her advice because
she's attacking me so i gotta attack
back i don't know make it like like you
really just should never be alone in a
in a bedroom with like
your daughter's man you know what i mean
like why would you even be in the same
room like you know maybe maybe like
there's there's baby in the room y'all
are like you know bantering whatever but
for the most part like why y'all in a
bedroom together like hang out in the
living room
like normal people
i
pass no way especially especially
because she said like if we're listening
to what she's saying right because she
already put the daughter down she
already put the the earth she put the um
her
grandbaby down so she already put the
baby down right and so
now you don't have an excuse to come to
the bedroom you could have easily gone
to the living room to have a full
conversation with the baby daddy okay
so
she's lying
okay